okay hi everyone
welcome to the second part of our design
review about spatial statistics
and modern language
so last time i think we had gotten
um
spatial
estimate
was our
name what's that yeah our candidate
named spatial estimator
probably right you wanted a noun
yes
or spatial estimation
okay
but let's let's just take a look at how
that actually works can i bring up
another issue i just want to put it on
the table and we can decide if you go to
that guide page
of which guide page spatial predict
that's one and listed in the design
review notebook
now if you click no no click on
i click the o button
did you no i don't know you're supposed
to get up the forum okay well let's see
it again okay um it says open guide page
no the other one to the right the little
one that or
that one now you type in
uh special yeah see it oh this is
remarkable yes isn't it wonderful
okay which one do i click special
prediction
okay
that was good roger yes that is a that
that's in the airplane cockpit of docky
tools yes
it's good really it's a good thing yeah
particularly on the mac it's so hard to
do you know the other way
okay i have to remember that arguably we
could make that button bigger okay go
ahead okay so here's a question for you
okay so data is super important for here
and so we want to leverage the wolfram
data repository
but
you know beyond using them in examples
i think it's very important on the guide
page to show sort of domains of data we
will seek out and curate data and add to
the wolfram data repository
so that we cover many different domains
now we need an idiom i would like an
idiom so we can show them on the guide
page
i would like to showcase data sets
on the guide page right well i mean so
what we've done in other places is
things like net model
you know is its own symbol
that is a specialized symbol which well
i mean that's its own repository as well
um this is a good question how to do
this okay i want to do this for not just
this function but for lots of functions
i want to showcase
not every data set but it's sort of a
variety so you can see the application
domains and this gives you a quick start
too because when you go to those pages
we build those pages for wolfram data
repository we will showcase the very
same functions and show like micro
workflows and so on
okay but the problem is
you know u.s ozone data in 2021
is something incredibly specific yeah
but i don't think it you know so the
thing is that we can gather a variety of
such data and it doesn't matter that
it's it's i've got a different
suggestion okay okay my suggestion is a
a page i don't know what it is exactly
it lives it's a essentially it's a guide
page for the data repository
and so what it would be is a page and
we've been talking about this actually
actually you know what this dovetails
with something else that's happening we
are making guide pages for the function
repository right actually i was going to
bring that up as another proposal as
well
if there is a guide page at the pa at
the at the repository level that we
curate
because then i can point to that and it
can be dynamically i think that's fine
and that's that's what we're planning
there's nobody here i think who knows
about that that's brady would know about
that but that's something i i think it's
almost done i think even for the
for
the function repository i believe that
that is if it isn't already deployed
it's about to be deployed right
i think that's good but i think it's
still valuable to be able to point to
individual data sets why don't you just
look i i don't think it's a great idea
on this page i think what you should do
is point to
the you know have a way to point to the
guide page which is then all data
you know which then has very specific
data on it
yeah
unless you have data look here's the
thing if it's data that is so generic
that is part of the you know ozone
levels in 2021 or swiss rainfall it's
just not anything that sample data isn't
generic data period end of story right
if you have for example the world's
rainfall data
or you have you know something like that
then that should be part of our entity
system and part of the the general
knowledge base right but probably what
you're saying now means that we can't
solve it for 13.00
um well you can strive
yes but but roger roger what i'm saying
is we're breaking into three pieces okay
one is data sets which could include
some of those um
you know nasa
oh gosh what are those things called
christopher knows about what i'm talking
about what are those
the the the endless
layers of that um
geo observation satellites the the
emission planet earth type thing yes
they have various programs that
satellite programs be running on that
but there's an aggregation of that what
is that wait sorry you mean the page
there's like there's like four four or
five different services where nasa tries
to consolidate all their satellite data
okay fine
yeah
okay but so that's an example something
like that and the gateway to something
like that that is a generic you know if
it's like vegetation of the world or
something
that's something that is as far as i'm
concerned that's a general knowledge
based thing but rainfall in switzerland
is not
right but actually it's valuable to have
specific data sets that can be i don't
know gold deposit levels in you know an
area in south africa i understand that
that's a sample data set okay exactly
i know i know but i'm saying
i'm saying
don't mix that up with
the the actual look there's one level is
the function it's full power functions
so what we used to do is example data
but we're trying to retire example data
i know we don't want to use that i don't
think it's a right idea i think i think
i need to be able to point to it yes i
know so what i would do is point to a
data repository guide page and you
should be able to get that for 13. those
those do
it's you know it should be close enough
you can get one of those
okay
i think it will be most likely on the
web right now because that's where the
data repository stuff lives but i
consider that not unacceptable
and i think were you thinking that we
would have one in here in the in
in documentation too yes
oh you could
we've built something that makes that
possible because
on one of those guide pages you need to
have pointers to actual data sets though
otherwise it makes no sense right of
course but those data sets will be in in
the on the web
right in the data repository yes yes yes
yes you eventually go to a page and you
get sort of the home page for the data
set yeah right but i'm saying if you
wanted to you could have the guide page
that links to that be an in-product
guide page if you care or it can be also
a cloud a web guide page right but
that's fine but then we come back to my
problem which i can sort out with tnu
docs of how to
how to mark that up yeah i know okay
that's a markup problem you they can
deal with that yeah i think that's the
right solution i think but then then i
think that you and i basically had the
same idea to begin with i'm just glad i
brought it up
okay but i think on that page yeah i
would say you know major data sets and
then then there are other ones which are
sure absolutely just samples and so on
but
i i want to make the other point which
is that i've been pushing to get geo
image and things like that to be able to
get for example layers of nasa data so
that you can have a curated thing but
you can say geo image of you know
massachusetts comma vegetation
i see that would be super interesting
that would be that would be a that's the
proper curation organization type thing
but but part of what we want to do when
showcasing kind of solver things like
this is to show that it applies to a
wide variety of domains well that's fine
but that can't be right
but we can't curate all the domains we
just we need to show that it applies
but given that you've now got this you
know spatial statistics stuff it makes
much more sense for us to have these
things like geo raster
of
you know blah blah blah vegetation and
things
yes
and i mean thank so the question is how
do we fork off that process of getting
those things curated
okay
yeah
um
i think that that's something probably
to talk to johannes team about
okay
roger you understand the objective right
well i think that i'm thinking the
driver for curating those kinds of
things would be new kinds of data
functions in the system you know like
entities and other queries like this
what i'm saying is i i'm talking about a
very specific thing okay
take the nasa data for example
these layers these you know
500 layers
of
you know remote sensing-ish data
you know vegetation level rainfall level
this that and the other tagging for
types of
you know climate zones whatever it is
right yeah okay each one of those
is something that
geo raster geoimage i'm not sure exactly
which
should be able to request
oh that means
go ahead sorry
no but then then i'm saying that that's
something that
when we develop those functions that's
what those functions would want
georester g yes i know i know i know i
know you know it's like a repository for
those guys
well but there's also so right and some
of that could probably be interfaced in
with the geo server something like the
geo server option for geo image already
um although it would have to have more
stuff in it but but there's also stuff
like um i do know that there are some of
the standard like nasa data sets are
like um point distributions or like what
are they called spatial point data
basically like where they had things
like um
oh i don't know like you know maps of uh
you know for example i know one of them
is they have like a map of like where
are their fires and they have a version
of it where they just have a point for
each fire and then metadata associated
with that point so that would be an
example where it's not a raster
yeah
right so i think what we need to know
roger is
beyond samples
right of the musee river or whatever
beyond those kinds of samples are there
global data sets that you want to be
able to access with the spatial
statistics functionality
not really
i mean i don't think no
no i i we've we've been exploring sort
of what the variety of where you should
have data of this form where data is
going to come from because this is a
processing function right
yeah and fine but but if there's another
one that's more like a database you know
like a data function
then its mission in life is to curate
data and have i understand that but so
the question that's being asked is this
we already know at the level of
rasters there's tons of data about the
earth
right already known
okay
which is worth curating we just haven't
done it yet right okay for spatial point
data we do not know
how much stuff there is that is kind of
whole earth data that's worth curating
that's something we should know
does that make sense
i don't we we've done some of that but i
don't know either because i think here's
a secondary
find out yeah the secondary thing is
that you can often
um the question is can you derive it
from other data
you know can you process your i
understand you know to
which is when you're interested in it
that's part of what you're going to try
to do cheapest way to acquire data i i
know but but we have a very specific
question here the question is in our
knowledge base is there something to
support all the work you guys have done
on processing functions is there
something that should be added to the
knowledge base
if the answer is no fine
if the answer is yes let's determine
that now rather than x years from now
yeah okay we'll we'll return to it we've
spent we've spent some time on it some
more time need to be spent
okay
but it sounds like christopher knows of
at least one database of some kind
um i think we're aware of that the nasa
database maybe we haven't spelunked as
deep as christopher
but
essentially on them on our live stream
ss is saying the european space agency
has sentinel 3 data apparently
and sl says very few fires in the us are
tagged with points they're usually
polygons
it depends they're like three different
there there are several different
sources for the for the fire data but
yeah okay i i know i know like for
example
the source word they i don't even know
what the standard format is for the
point data but i know like on the i
think it's called the nasa earth view
which is one of their more
like easier to interface with systems
that they they had us they have a bunch
of raster layers and they also have
these point layers
okay i mean there's a thing called world
view okay so here we go so this is
welcome to world view okay
so most of these as a raster data
yeah now the main problem with this one
though is the fact that the raster data
they don't it's none of it's like um
uh
like
they they don't give you the the raw the
raw numerical values they just like if
you get something like the temperature
map it'll be on a scale from blue to red
right which isn't very useful if you
want to
process it in any way right you can't
actually get the number for the
temperature
i see i went i was wondering whether
somewhere on the site they actually have
a thing where they've broken down their
data sets by what type of data it is
there is an api behind this site where
you can access all that stuff but it's
still uh
yeah
okay
and the one thing that i noticed when i
a long time ago when i went in looking
there is that they've had funding that
goes for a program of satellites
and they build a website then there's
another program for another cluster of
satellites and they built their owner
you know
sure website and so it's kind of like a
right big mess
right
um
okay
so um
okay
let's let's keep going here all right we
were talking about spatial estimator or
spatial so let's walk through you we
were talking last time about variograms
and all that stuff so barogram if we
want to drill into that today because
that's the the sort of the meat and
potatoes of this thing
okay
well but but let's go let's go checking
this function first so what
the proposal right now will be to call
this spatial estimation
is that a reasonable name i mean
racial okay so
what it's eating is either
location value
or
wait a minute spatial point data wait a
minute what annotation of spatial point
data
is this picking up as values here
in this example
this is where they
this was coded
using spatial point data and there's one
annotation that happens to be continuous
which is the ozone level apparently
okay so so what this is saying is
okay i don't understand this okay
okay look guys point value plot is
picking up some value there which value
is it picking up from data down here
we're saying it's the ozone annotation
that we're plotting but what's it
plotting here
good point it is plotting those on
levels okay so how did it know to do
that yeah
how did it well that's how i you know
that the lead the example says ozone
readings over continuous united states i
i understand that and if you ex no no no
no you misunderstand gosha why did point
value plot know to pick up that
annotation because it's the only
annotation ah okay fine so in that case
there is no reason you can't feed
spatial estimation or spatial estimator
or whatever it is why you can't just
feed it spatial point data because if
point plot date a point value plot
we could try we could try then this
other thing could do it may not be
continuous but we'll try no i understand
but my point is this
what does point value plot do if there
are three different annotations
in special points point value plot is
made to to illustrate all three
you know this is like what does it do
well if you go to point value plot you
can put a bar chart for instance you
know at each point
it will try to also we can use a shape
colors yeah colors or shapes for the
color can't do more than one dimension
realistically okay so so this is a this
is a super function yes that's trying to
do
yeah it says a whole language you know
and this is not even as far developed as
we intended it you know okay so so i'm
going to make the statement because
friends are pushing back on but it's
obviously the right answer but spatial
estimation should be the same way that
is if there is categorical data in
spatial estimation it should try and
deal with that if there's this it should
deal with that it should also be a super
function working the same kind of way
that point value plot works
okay but now you're confused again
because
gautier is doing she's abusing the
function here
this is for discrete you know like
cities okay you can have a number of
annotations for a city let's say there's
50 things that you know about a city
can you summarize those for each city i
know
that's what it is roger i got it roger
i got it
this is the same mistake we gotta not
make this design mistake again right
once you give people a general function
it should do the best it can i don't
care that you've got you know a whale is
not a fish right you can you can say all
you want a whale is not a fish so we
can't do this or that thing with a whale
but the whale is a great big you know
creature flapping around in the ocean
and there's a lot of things that are
relevant to whales that are things
connected to fine we're going to be on
spatial statistics longer it's going to
be for 13 1 we're going to deal with
categorical data in spatial estimator we
don't need we're going to have to make
this version one we're going to make the
theory for it we're going to build the
theory i don't mind i like development
roger we don't need to do it for version
one
so version two comes for thirteen one so
we don't need to do it we don't need to
do it yet we don't need to do it yet but
don't make the whale is not a fish
mistake
right it's just you can say this isn't
supported yet sorry just like we've had
things which for 25 years we've said
this is not supported yet and turns out
nobody cares
and when people show up and say you know
can you please support you know
factoring multivariate polynomials over
extension fields or whatever it is
you know
that's been a
the design is there
but the implementation is not there and
that's fine
but let's not break the design
yeah i'm not sure this design makes
sense for categorical data probably okay
well let's think it through
let's think it through
okay so
okay
the first point here
you know it's always
it's always disappointing when the
simplest example is this long
so let me just understand i mean
basically our representation
of
yeah i mean i understand this
i understand that representation
you know we should be able to package it
into this and what we should be able to
do
is say something like
given that spatial point data i don't
know what the right syntax is here
but
you know maybe we want just spatial
point data arrow and then the name of
the annotation
that is i don't know that would be great
that would be consistent that would be
fine
is it consistent with other things
something like that yeah i mean we do
all kinds of things like sometimes for
an association we ignore the keys and we
take the values right okay so that would
deal with this problem and then what
would happen is if spatial point data
has only one annotation then it just
takes that if it doesn't you qualify it
by saying spatial point data arrow the
name of the annotation that you want to
use for the for the um
uh for the values that's for sure does
that make sense to you it does make
sense
yes
okay
um all right so now let's walk through
the rest of what this is doing
okay
so
i wasn't keen on these names spatial
trend model because that suggests to me
what the heck is a one there
it's a fortran
no no this just if you go to that page
you know it considers polynomial models
of certain degrees
so this is linear
okay
also why isn't it spatial trend order or
something
because you can have a general model as
well
what is the general model the last case
if you have a family that you think
that the mountain or whatever it is
satisfy you could fit that
i see
so what we've done like for
interpolation order it's just an order
right yeah
because there is nothing okay so where
do we have this other kind of case where
we can have more arbitrary functions as
the fitting parameters fitting things uh
fine fit
and so but in that case the arguments
but didn't want to make this a two-stage
process where you have to
um
we want this to be a super function
which means that you can do it sort of
in one go you don't do multiple step
steps no i agree i agree it's just the
name of this thing
is
what's bothering me is that model is a
verb
well no well it's i mean it's not a verb
in this case right yeah it's hard to
understand
i also hate seeing things like spatial
10 model arrow one it reminds me of
fortran
even though i understand in your i i
don't know fortran so nothing reminds me
of fortran pretty much well in in you
know the imsl you know mathematical
function libraries no i know i know i
just you know you want you want to do
gaussian quadrature it's a it's three
i see okay well that's not what it is
here it's not i know it doesn't i know
it is it's a meaningful thing right
um i mean it could have you know it
could be a a list of quotes polynomial
and then comma order
you know i'm not i'm not worried about
that i'm worried about the name of the
option that's all i'm worried about okay
okay
um
but you see what i'm worried about if
you just see that name spatial trend
model yeah that suggests to me oh i feed
it data it's going to make a model for
me
it will
no it won't
this is not a function this is not a
function no but in the process in the
processing pipeline it makes i don't
care that name suggests that it is a
function that does something that's what
i'm complaining about well there might
also be the interpretation of model as
like a verb that's right that's what i'm
saying right but we can avoid that okay
then we're in good shape so how do we
avoid that
um
ignored model just spatial trend
no because that again seems like a verb
find the spatial trend but that's what
it's doing but it's not roger it's an
option to a function but it's finding a
spatial trend not it is
it's not
finding anything it is specifying what
kind of spatial trend you want to be
looking for in the data in order to do
the fit exactly that's why
roger it is not finding anything it is
not find fit it is an option about what
kind of fitting you do yeah what kind of
model to use i know which is an option
not an action function right
okay look for example
we could have we would have something
that says fitting function right
something like that
that would be a a typical name for a
thing like this or nearest function
nearest function doesn't find the
nearest that's nearest that finds the
nearest nearest function
is a function called within another
function that's trying to do something
else that is finding nearest you see
what i'm saying
did you get it
i think you're thinking of distance
function but i am thinking distance
function
right yeah the distance we want a name
that is the analog of distance function
that represents this is the trend
you are
um you are trying to use space
function
if it's a function that will be just
fine
but you don't want to give the function
then that's the lot of manual work for
each user right i understand eric on our
live stream suggests spatial trend
method which i agree is not bad
no
okay
look i assume that there's a reason it
couldn't just be method is there is
there are other other options that are
basically uh these shouldn't be methods
yeah they shouldn't be this is a this is
a perfectly prime thing that it's doing
the problem is it's just a naming
problem okay let's solve the naming
problem rather than pretending it
doesn't exist
okay if you see this disembodied name
you will get the wrong idea about what
it does
that's the problem we have to solve
i mean spatial trend modeling but i
don't particularly like that either
that sounds like something that would be
true or false
yeah i know
in other languages it would be special
trend modelization world just spatial
trend without the model
no because that suggests that it's doing
something like a fit
it is you see
no it's not roger it's an option to a
function that does the fit
true yes right
that's what we have to capture in that
name
okay can we table it for a sec and then
do some others maybe we'll come up with
a
naming scheme instead more because there
will probably be objections to other
names here too well yeah let's look at
these other names
where else have we had a similar thing
well we have to assume i mean in time
series we have a similar thing don't we
do you know what i'm saying
no we don't particularly yes we do i
think it's called i think it's just
interpolation function or it's something
like that
there's stuff like missing value method
which is maybe a bit similar yeah but
they are
okay so these ones are all called method
yeah because they're pretty much at that
level they don't have any
yeah
okay but so i don't know they're they're
big method options though like i mean if
you look at you know the machine
learning functions or like predictor
classify they have massive method
options of course
yes right the the point roger is making
here is that this thing is a somewhat
understandable value that's being given
here somewhat understandable setting
it's not a giant bank switch method like
thing
no that's the point you're making you're
making the point that you could imagine
programmatic access to this rather than
just bank switching
right
okay and that's what you say you're
trying to capture that in this name
which is fine except that that name is
wrong well hold on though i mean isn't
that isn't that also the case with you
know the the the predict methods or the
classify methods i mean they have their
own documentation pages because they're
expected to you know to to give it
detailed information about what type of
okay but that's the that's the
difference okay another name for what
we're giving here is so these are model
structures they basically says what
family of models are you considering
okay but those methods that you refer to
in machine learning
those are
separate frameworks that have their own
set of options and and and ways of
controlling them
you know
they're dramatically different from each
other and they have basically they're
separate frameworks look it's a little
bit verbose but spatial trend model
structure would be fine by me that would
be fine by me too because that's what
they are
this model families basically like
models with parameters if you like you
know
and that's kind of what they are
it's just like short names for some of
them
model family might be nicer than model
structure also yeah model families model
family model structure is sort of the
same well what is model family arrow 2
is that i mean maybe it should be
a string polynomial comma two and the
two is just sort of a shorthand for that
fine well you can certainly document
polynomial comma comma n yeah i think we
should because
okay now are these consistent well where
this thing is
i don't quite understand this this is a
uh what's the x y here and this f1 f2
are those pure functions or what
those are functions of the x and y
but why is there x and y here at all
because those are the coordinates of
your points but why aren't they
appearing in these cases here
because
because those those
the last one is is very flexible it
doesn't give any you know it's not
restricted to
a sort of a fixed class you know you can
come up with them yourself
you know they can be very confused i i
would have thought what if you gave like
say a radio
i mean actually now that i think about
it i wonder if they should you know that
variables probably shouldn't be there
they should just be functions of the
points probably i think so
i think that's the right that actually
is a good point stephen let's get rid of
those variables and just have a set of
basis functions basically that are
functions of the points
and
that's the valid
right hand side is still valid you know
which just that the coding of it needs
to be different handles
why don't we call this spatial trend
function because these things can
actually just be functions this thing
here could be hash
you know hash theta ampersand no theta
ampersand and this thing here could be
you know you can easily have you know
why not just call it spatial trend
function
um
[Music]
because it is basically
basically and allow it to take an
arbitrary appeal function this is a list
of pure functions
yes we would have to decide
how we
specify or the design for how we specify
the
the single integer which is the kind of
shorthand but
that's okay that's okay
we can still have this this notation
that's so the single integer is fine the
single integer or you know list
polynomial comma integer that's still
fine that's sort of this just means
those functions you know right
that's like for if you have you know
let's say degree two polynomials in two
variables yeah it has three basis
functions
that of total degree two
and you enumerate them
all right so what we think we're going
towards the spatial trend function which
i like very much that makes perfect
sense it's in line with our other naming
okay
all right let's keep going here
so
spatial variogram model
is that the same story again
it relates to model bariogram right so
the the which i don't yet understand
right hopefully very soon you will okay
but is it is it the same story where
it's a function or is it the same story
where it's a
where it's a method or what is it it's a
function okay so if you scroll down
let's scroll down it's a variable
function so we just call it spatial
variogram function
that's the algorithm model variogram
yeah
yeah i guess it could be that that
oh but variogram function is the output
the model barigram
who cares what's wrong with that so this
thing here becomes
well that's a bit confusing
so this is spatial variagam
okay
spatial variogram function
is an option then to
to
spatial estimate
right
and
it is also a thing that you could get
spatial variogram function
it's a little bit confusing what the
difference between that and variogram
function is
yeah what is the meaning of the word
variogram really
it's the expected
um it's the ver um go go to their model
variogram the definition is actually the
short the the definition is up here
okay
it was in the same page okay okay um see
there after those pictures yep gamma of
two points
okay and this is the the x is sort of a
process at those points
what's the variance
of the difference between those two
points but what is a gram i mean usually
when something says it like a histogram
oh diet
no
unfortunately
now graham was just a popular naming
convention in the 50s and 60s
you know so we have spectrogram we have
but a spectrogram is a picture
yeah but the sociogram is like a matrix
but but that's how it started because it
was plotting
so they were plotting this you know like
these values like that they get from
data and therefore variogram because
they were plotting things to see how
this variance changes with the distance
between the points that's what the bin
variogram is doing for the data and
therefore the model is also called
variogram
okay so hold on right now we have a
function here
called
model variagram
yeah which produces a picture or
produces a function a function
oh boy is that confusing okay what has
been variable by the way just just for
context i mean when i go online look up
variable
i i there's no plots it's all it's all
descriptions of of
you know
it's not a visualization right that pops
out i think grams don't have to be
pictures you see gram everything was
supposed to be gram it seemed to me in
the 50s and 60s
i think we grew out of the graham
naming era
i just thought graham was short for
diagram
and thought i thought histogram
spectrogram we're all
you know i think ram comes from greek to
write
yes what graphy graph is the
is the um
that's the root you know i have this
very convenient book called composition
of scientific words let me look up
graham in that
um let's find out what it is actually
they have the ending in the animal
etymological dictionary whatever it says
it's
uh from grammar and greek that which is
drawn or a picture
but it seems that that's kind of
yeah
that's that's what i'm trying to tell
you that it's historically what what
people were doing spatials you know did
creating they were doing this
data and then the way that of the
presenting the computations was to plot
that so it was a plot it's not
it's now it's it's it's a computation
and we have models for that so yeah we
okay so this is also interesting that a
lot of compute methods you know going
back to you know the early 1900s maybe
up to the 60s and so on where graphical
you know that was a way to compute in
many
grams for example yeah yeah yeah and in
control engineering people used
um basically graphical methods of
fourier transforms and other things to
do designs
right you know people have
i know
and nyquist plots they were you know
basically design tools from which you
you you did your compute
right
okay so this is confusing and it will be
really nice if our functions didn't end
with variogram because to the typical
average person it'll be like that's a
plot
what is it
does this dendrogram does the output of
dendrogram is that computable or is it
just physical no it's plot
okay
i believe everything we have
that is a gram is a plot
we will determine that in one second
here
parallelogram okay special exception for
parallelogram
inverse spectrum
gram well it's kind of you know
it's
look everything else is a plot
okay so let's have a think about that
okay so let's just first understand what
variagram actually does
yeah
and um
um
okay
i'm sorry the the king function here i
mean the spatial estimation
what is it going to do it's going to
take
a special estimator should it be spatial
estimator that's what i think that
returns a spatial estimator function
right that's what i think it should be
so actually what's the what's the verb
noun edge whatever for um
uh feature extract feature extractor
feature extraction
um good point what is that
well like i could tell you what it is i
mean feature feature ex extraction
is the thing that returns a feature
extract tor function
it's just it might as well be consistent
with this although at the same time i do
every single time i use these have to
look up which one is rich yeah me too i
i certainly don't yeah
well and then feature extract
in this particular case is a rather
um impoverished function because feature
extract is very rarely useful on its own
right i mean that's the thing that
okay so feature extract is the one shot
i'm going to give you the answer
feature extraction
is the thing that is going to give you a
function that you can repeatedly apply
so where does this lie in that space
the ladder
okay let's go through that again what
it's exactly doing so it's it's giving
you
so it's going to return to you a
function
that effectively gives you a continuous
value
you know where they're you know where
there are no point you know for every
point
even if you're only finitely many points
and point values in
look i think spatial estimator is the
most obvious name for this because that
it is what it it is returning to you a
spatial estimator
and then it will be a spatial estimator
function
that is returned
i agree i like that
all right okay there was there was there
any particular reason i mean i i also
agree but was there any particular
reason why it was feature extraction
and a feature extractor function instead
of just being a feature extract door and
it produces a feature extractor function
i'm not sure
that argument what's that
no maybe it's because there's two of
them i find
feature extraction more confusing like
it seems like it's it's like
it's like talking about it in an
abstract way oh no no there is also a
feature extractor now that i think about
it because that's yet a different thing
that's yet a different thing that's an
option oh my god
okay
and in fact we have to worry about that
because yeah we needed for to name four
things
right so the concern would be spatial
estimator
could be
okay so here's a question if if you're
if you've got a function
to be perfectly honest it seems like it
should have been the other way around
because you could imagine having an
option where you'd say something like
feature extraction arrow none or
something like that
right like
objectives
feature extract tor is very nice i mean
look at look at how nicely that goes
classify there's the feature extractor
that you're going to use
right but i just think that it could i
think it's more natural like i think
it's equally natural to say feature
extractor or feature extraction right
there
but for the usage of feature extraction
it's more natural to call it feature
extractor if that makes sense
possibly i'm not convinced i really like
this usage here but my question is is
there anything for which
a spatial estimator
would be the option name we wish we had
so i think looking forward um
i might as well bring this up now okay
um this is another can
but it's a beautiful can but
but it's a can that doesn't have so the
worms are really really elegant yes
so the thing is that
you when you do let's say list plot or
list 3d
there is right now the use case we do is
interpolation it will go through the
points
okay we can still set the order and it
will have you know will show phenomena
sometimes ringing phenomena if you have
like a third order
but
a common use case is that you think your
data isn't actually perfect there might
be noise in your data
in which case
you don't want the curve that joins them
to go through every point
i think we should have something like
fitted list plot that does that right
the problem is is that worth having um
you know um so think about how many list
functions we have
yeah so you're suggesting an interpreter
something beyond interpolation order
that's a a fitting you know that we we
call it fitting function or something
that
represents something that
draws the curve
independent because remember there's a
bunch of other hair inside list plot
that you know like like the thing that
draws the points as well as the line and
things like that yes all of that and all
kinds of things i i don't think it's
trivial to not go through the points
we'll come to that i think it's a
heavily requested thing and it's some of
the things that we are sort of missing
because we even well i do think that
that i would like to say that thing i
would really like to have
is a trend line for example not not as a
piece of graphics stuff so that trend
line we're in jam more generally trend
surface trend curve that is what we're
talking about
okay fine but but to me then but that
means that they won't be as wiggly as
the ones that we do now no no i know
that but what i want to do is to have
something where i can get out the trend
line so to speak and somehow have that
be like like we have axes that i can
just put in a trend line i can say trend
line of data or i could say trend line
of data with three points removed or
something so in other words the trend
line becomes like an axis
that i can put into a plot that i can
add into a plot
interesting idea
but the function that does that is the
one that we're designing right now that
will be the one that we use yeah okay
that's what i would recommend rather
than a rather than an incredibly
elaborate option
cascade of for you know
for the for the list plot itself but
there's a detail i mean okay
add a trend line add a trendline but
then you're going to have to have all
kinds of details about whether it
excludes outliers blah blah blah blah
blah blah and you know i think
right i mean there's probably a kind of
a an easy button of just add a trendline
to the data that's already there to all
the data that's there and that's like a
grid line type option and then a
different thing which is a trendline
symbolic wrapper that allows you to have
much more control
yep all good ideas okay so so anyway but
back to this i mean i can i can i um
comment on the special estimator
for me this rings more as an option name
we have process estimator as an option
in estimated process and if we ever want
to
think about adding spatial processes
then it would be an okay that was
exactly what i was asking for
yes okay i get it so i think spatial
estimation is what we have to go with so
i would s so i what i would
vote for would be spatial estimate
not estimation necessarily i i
understand but then stephen will object
to the fact that that's a verb and you
get a function that actually does it
well but a special estimate
it's not terrible
it's not terrible specialist special
estimation
i could live with special estimate
i mean in a sense nearest does this oh
the nearest doesn't do is none of the
above nearest is a
um you know it's an adjective so it's
even even not at all the same kind of
thing but
the spatial estimate give me the spatial
estimate
i think this would be okay spatial
estimate and then the question what
would be the output so that would be the
spatial
estimator function estimator function i
think so because that's because if you
ever have
a spatial estimator as an option one of
the things you can feed it is surely one
of these special estimator functions
correct
isn't that right
probably
depends on how we implement it but yeah
right but the spatial estimator function
is fed
basically what that is given is an xy
pair
and or whatever it is does this work in
any number of dimensions yes it does
um you know so
you give it
a
um
you give it a list of coordinate you
give it a coordinate x y or whatever and
it returns
the thing that was the annotation
for the point
the estimated annotation for the point
at that point is that correct
yes
it's kind of weird that it's the so is
it is it a is it a an association
what does it actually return it's only
you
i'm sorry the volume
no but there isn't a value because
they're multiple annotations
oh you're feeling it something which has
a is a singularly annotated that's right
yes it's a single scalar field yes
although in the future we talked about
the vector case and in the future it
could be an association
and
to just feed that through in the future
future all you give it is spatial point
data that has an association as the
annotation at every point and then what
this does is to make a function that
returns for every x y point the
association of annotations at that point
sure
okay that all makes sense to me
okay let's take a look here all right
so
let's go to spatial variables
noise variance again that sounds to me
like something that computes spatial
noise variants
um
what what what is that doing that's
assuming a noise variance is that
correct yes yes
and so the more
noise the more noisy if you know
something about your sensors let's say
it has a certain resolution or something
like that yeah then you can give it
okay that tells us roughly what the
noise okay so in the value space
and that tells you how much you should
trust the value right i understand so
this would be like saying you're going
to do a fit
and there are really a rounds wrapped
around every point of the fit yes we
have a mechanism for doing that
so in other words for a fit assume this
error bound for every point yeah we can
get out it's one of the properties that
we can get out of that particular
function is the
um you know we can get a rounds out
basically and we can get the the the
variance out for each point but the
noise variance really controls the
discontinuity of the variogram model at
the origin
okay nice okay so what were we talking
it's the rounds at the the uncertainty
at the end of the result yes i get it
but i'm i'm i think i get it but i'm
what i'm saying is you could imagine
something where you're doing a fit
just ordinary data points no spatial
anything right just random data points
right
and those data points if we do
and increasingly i hope we will do even
more of fitting taking into account the
fact that there is an error on every
point and a round on every point right
yeah
okay so my point is
that one could imagine an option two
fitting functions that says assume this
amount of fuzziness for every point
okay we don't to my knowledge we do not
have that capability right now to assume
fuzziness for every point
is that correct you can put fuzziness in
constantly by putting it around for
every point now i think hold on does
linear model fit i think that the
fitting functions actually do that
okay let's take a look at what they do
those fitting functions could do the
facelift
yes
very much so
i mean among other things they really
should use associations
no
okay
so i mean what this is
on the other hand i'm thinking the
variance estimator function it could be
probably given a constant value
i'm guessing
you know
right
so that probably is a way to do it
yeah that's a function for estimating
the error variance so right
using variance one and there's like a
bullet there's a note below
there is a
there is a way to give them constant
variance yeah there is a way
because a function is more general than
just a constant
yeah here it is
oh i see it's treated as the known
uncertainty of measurement that's
exactly the same thing you're doing here
right
so maybe just reuse variance estimator
function
we've got spatial trend function
variance estimator function
yeah
yes
we could okay
fine
um
all right let's let's continue all
coming it down
so to speak
okay let's look at variogram function
well no we want to look at variogram
spatial variogram model
okay so i think i'm going to have to
actually understand this now yeah
so vodka so so the the thing that
contains the meat
and this one points to that the model
variogram page that one really explains
it this is
wait a minute this is an option this is
not even what i want right what i want
is that is the page
that i'm totally confused by what is it
called spatial variable what is it no
model variogram oh this is just an
unbelievably confusing name because this
uses it's model based
okay but but but but okay this idea that
we end with variogram is horrible
horrible horrible horrible
i mean this
model i think that would be better
except that then
right
no i mean out comes a function
that is the variable okay that that's
fine but then
okay what do you mean that is the
variogram i mean this is the problem
that used to be a page a piece of paper
that people drew
that then turned into a slang
for
you know
an for a variogram function what does
the variable function eat
what are the arguments the variable
function
it's a radius
i think it does it doesn't need pairs of
functions i think it needs
it's really is because it's defined for
the distances if i might say so could
you please give an example here where
you just take
this is in the variogram function page
where you just take a varigram function
and feed it seven and it gives you a
number just so we understand the next
the second example on this page
it doesn't do that that's a very i mean
this is the the the problem is that you
you the the way to get the variogram
function yeah i need to show you how to
get the variogram function
so why not just put a variogram function
is as an example we just wanted to just
have a variable function sitting there
as input because you can do that right
okay yeah it can be coming out of the
blue yeah
i think so i think it's a good idea i
think it's a good thing to do in general
for these functions where it's like you
know the first question is what does the
animal eat so to speak and then we can
say how do you make the animal
see what i mean
okay
so
what's that chicken and egg problem
yes yes yes right
the
um
okay so in this case what you're saying
is the variogram function returns this
thing which i'm about to understand
which is what happens
okay what is a variate ram
fits a model the spatial field data and
returns this
so this is
the variogram for a spatial process is
given by the variance okay so you take
you have the random field you take two
points
and you're asking
what's the variable difference
so
a variogram function is taking a radius
what you've got here is two points yeah
this is general definition so in the
most generality yes
follow next year
stephen follow the next line we are
working in a
in a stationary case where we have
isotropic field
that's where the definition
that we're using here is that's why it
works on the radius in the radial
setting
what is the difference between spatial
variance the concept of spatial variance
and this concept here i don't know what
spatial variance is
well it's obvious meaning would be
something like this yeah but see that's
a scalar thing coming out of there x
exadat is a scalar value
so it's a variance
sorry i don't understand the the x x
x you know the the field
at over a point is a distribution
it's a scalar distribution
okay or random variable if you like
right at every point
in the base space
there is a random variable
yes and this is asking
what is
the variance integrated over for two
particular points in space
what is the variance of the difference
between the values for those two points
yeah right so for example if those two
points were both delta function
distributions fixed values then this
quantity would simply be the difference
of the values with the mysterious
divided by two there
no it wouldn't be no no i'm wrong i'm
wrong i'm wrong or wrong it'll be zero
the variance will be zero this is the
difference of those distributions the
variance of the difference of those
distributions
yes
okay
okay but so now
you're saying if it's stationary and
isotopic
then this quantity is just characterized
by the distance between the points p1
and p2
exactly
okay
but you are not in fact supporting you
can't feed the animal p1 p2 you can only
feed the animal r is that correct that's
correct
okay so i don't think this is correctly
named
because because the variogram as you're
saying is this quantity they're all
called the variogram
great
okay
okay well let's try and un-confuse
people by by breaking this apart somehow
okay so what does this say
but just follow it because we have okay
that's what you're seeing okay
so
i don't understand why this is the white
noise variation this is the varigram for
white noise
distribution right
yeah when there is
but i think you shouldn't say varigame
though i think you should say white
noise this this case here is white noise
and this is the result for the very i
would say white noise so
if you go online and you look up
variagram all you see are these plots
like as far as i can tell so my
understanding is the variogram and
correct me if i'm wrong the variable is
basically the function that that tells
you like you know the basic chord
spatial correlation you know
how correlated two points are as a
function of distance right yes so for
white noises there's no it doesn't
matter what the distance is there's a
correlation right this is always the
same right but then then your
documentation here says the variogram
but you're saying in the current slang
so what you're saying is the slang went
this way first it was a picture
then it was
this again a field right actually it's a
more complicated object here this is a
field with two you know two coordinates
here
and then it degenerated into a pure
you know
correlation as a you know essentially
radial correlation function right so the
first one is is a function of two n
variables
then they simplify to a single variable
right
yes we're giving two end variables no
the first thing is the first thing you
know there's like this end coordinates
of p1 there's n coordinates for p2 so
gamma here is a function of two n
variables
in the fully non-isotropic case and
non-stationary non-isotropic etcetera
yes that's correct okay
now
when it's stationary it's really a
function of the difference so now it's a
function of only n variables okay when
it's isotropic it's no function of only
a single variable and it's not it's not
a variable it's a it's a oh yeah yeah
single scalar value yeah radius right
right
okay so first question are we always
assuming
stationarity and isotropy yes
right that's that's why we have the
trend option because if you have the
trend in the field then overruns your
you know your dependencies so that's why
that's important to determine your data
because only then these models make
sense in modeling okay so what are these
doing here the daggum whatever that is
so this is this this when you look at
the plots they tell you how this
dependence is this variation is shaping
so when you have two points in the
distance very close the value of the
field will also change you know this
much when you when you increase the
distance you will see you know how much
how soon the variety of the variation
will increase
and so you have the the steepness you
have the slope you have the shape you
have the distance you're answering a
different question
i don't understand
where do you put these in
uh well you can put them in as
as
you put them into the
the model here so you can put model
comma parameters so that's the fourth
uh the one with the with the fixed
parameters that's the wait a minute so
you're saying that model variagram i
love that one called euclid's hat
whatever there was one down there called
euclid's hat i wonder what they did
where in alexandria back in those days
anyway the
um
some kind of you know maybe maybe with
some kind of fez type thing
who knows
um
so you can fit this model to your data
or you can explicitly ask for it
is euclid's hat i'm sorry why on earth
is this called euclid's hat
okay but in any case what you're saying
is
that what you can get out it will always
be
some kind of variogram function
yes that variogram function will operate
using euclid's hat or using spherical or
using whatever else yes and the
parameters yes right i understand but
those parameters will be hidden from you
those parameters will be ingested as
part of the variogram function they will
not be
no so there are two ways to look at that
if you if you have data and you ask for
elk it's head it's it will estimate the
parameters from the data
but also if you want i know what my abcs
are and i want to work with that you can
also put them directly and get the
function with your specific abc
parameters in it
function so in variogram function you
can feed in a euclid's hat yes it's your
particular a b and c yes right yes
that makes sense right but so so this is
a way of generating a variogram function
this this function its mission in life
is to generate a variogram function yes
perigram function that's guaranteed to
also so this is a subtlety the the you
did probably before that big table of
things
there is a subtlety
stop okay look here
a variogram function even one of those i
guess it doesn't go through the points
yeah no but it needs to satisfy these
kind
of
negative definite
so so the whole the whole kind of reason
why we have this bunch of models is
because when we just compute this this
bin variogram from data from the
beginning what we get you know we can
say we can we have some functions
directly from data
that function is not satisfied it's not
uh guaranteed to satisfy this condition
that you know that this proper model
must in order for all this special
estimation increasing to actually make
sense
and and therefore we don't just use
directly what we get from data but we
fit what we get from data so the bin
variogram and we use this to feed the
models which are kind of you know on a
white list so they're the good models
that satisfy the condition
and then this is then fed into the
special estimation you know to to give
you the
the values in the field
okay okay let's let's walk through this
again
okay
variagram function
seems like a perfectly good name
that
can be then used
in
where it is
in spatial predict so that would be
that's crazy that's crazy
i'm sorry we're going to end up with a
name spatial variogram
model
that's absolutely crazy right so we have
a variogram function
oh my gosh let me think about this for a
second
the variogram function
returns again verigram function is fed
what again what does it eat so the whole
data the the variogram function its
distances so that's your okay so it's
simply a parameterization it's it's
going to be in a first approximation a
euclid hat with particular a b and c
yeah okay
and this is what you can say specify
that i want to use that as my variogram
model the spatial variogram model which
is gonna be fed to the spatial estimate
i get it i get it i get it okay so let's
walk through what the okay so then
in spatial
estimate it will be calling
if you don't give it a special variogram
model it will call
this horribly named function model
variogram underneath yes
to x to get the variogram function that
it should be using
by variogram function what we
essentially mean is a radial correlation
function-ish thing
right that's what it is it's just some
radial function
yes um
okay
so let me let me let's walk through what
these things actually are
so variogram function
boy
okay
this here this option to spatial
estimate
is
the variogram function to assume
for processing that data correct
correct
okay
now meanwhile
there are some named
variogram functions
which are some of the things that you
could have used here and presumably if
we said
and i don't even understand what the
word spatial variogam is isn't a
variogram already a spatial kind of
creature what is a variogram where it's
not doing this thing with a spatial
value field
um
i don't know
we chose spatial just
because it like grounds the
the function in in kind of like i get it
but if a variogram can't be used for
anything else it's like saying
um
what's a good example
uh
hexadecimal base
no that's a bad example but you know
something where you repeat the name
again so to speak
if verigram means a spatial
statistic i mean the other thing to
remember is that all these options i
think are for connoisseurs
i think i realized that the the the key
use case is when you specify no option
i i realize all of that but you're not
going to convince me that we shouldn't
do a good job of naming them okay
but but but the point is they can be
named quite definitely
right okay so let's go walk through this
again
what we've got is something which is the
the parametrized
all these different named variogram
functions
right that's one thing is we've got to
represent the named variogram
thing
okay
that's just it's just a function that is
you know it's a function of a variable
it's just you know it's an f of f of r
that's all
it is yes but it's also does estimation
no it doesn't yes
no it doesn't this function does model
variogram does yes
function does not paragraph
functionality it's already estimated
right yeah paragraph function is just a
euclid hat
or something else right so where else in
the system do we have something where it
is i mean these are essentially special
functions of the variogrammic world
right but we thought that you don't want
20
new functions
no we don't right we don't so the
question is where we could have the wind
land barrier ground no no
roger roger where in the system do we
have something where you have a block i
mean it's like net model right net model
is
has
a bunch of named models right but it is
all in the net model thing
so i would have thought that
okay so actually i've got an idea here
okay so my claim is
variogram model
should take in it pentaspherical euclid
hat or whatever it is right
this should be the thing
that verigram model
i claim
could be the thing that
let's see
that this is the thing that eats r and
returns a number
possibly
yes
then then we've got
the thing that estimates
so what i would say
is that
why not call it variogram model estimate
because that takes data and returns a
variagram model
then
that's the right name for it it's
estimate because that's what it's doing
is similar to a fitting function right
it's returning
you know this is like fit it happens to
be a fit of the abcs here in the euclid
hat as opposed to a polynomial fit or
something like that but it's basically a
fit
right okay the other language is
estimated variable model
in the language of distributions and
processes
but which one is okay so this will be
estimated estimated
variogram model that one there no this
is that's not estimated because you're
going to give the data here so it
doesn't make sense this is just the
model
that we don't want to introduce the new
the new symbol
okay well so i don't know whether this
is estimated variogram model that would
be fine by me that's that's the question
now which way the estimate goes in front
or on the on the end
well okay if this is consistent with the
rest of the statistics thing that'll be
okay with me then we've got one more
thing to name if i'm not mistaken which
is the option in spatial estimate
right
so but we're still keeping variogram
function right
that becomes variogram model
that's what verigram variable gram
function is very gram model that that's
the thing that has a euclid hat and eats
radii
right because that's the special
function right it's just it's a
variogram model
that's a euclid hat model that eats
7.4 radius type stuff right
okay it's just that um
the way that we have the variogram
function right now when it's obtained
through fitting it has additional
information in it oh great we can put
additional information here that's fine
put all kinds of additional information
there but fundamentally this is a grand
model
that if i'm not it can be both a
constructor and an output gaussian
yes it's a little tricky but we can do
it
well i mean i think that's the right way
to do that
we've had
we've had functions that they can
structure i i think i'm going to vote
against having the same name for the
constructor like but
okay yeah that's my personal vote
well what do you by the way we have only
another five minutes here and then we
have to wrap this
um
and uh
um
so noise is the last one to look at them
the noise nick is commenting is temporal
variogram a thing
yes
so there is a notion of spatial
variogram
should this be called spatial variable
should the whole branding of these
variograms be spatial variogram and we
we used spatial to brand a whole set of
i know but this isn't called spatial
we're proposing ferrogram model and
maybe that should be special variogram
model
so on my all my very superficial
googling of variograms everything i find
defines them as being
about spatial correlation i think
you know but but just as you know so the
two ways to do it i don't have
covariation and there are sort of three
variants of that
you know correlation
guys guys we're running out of time okay
okay
the proposal would be this is the
special function that each radii
okay then we've got how do you get one
of those from data right i personally
think verigram model estimate would be
the more consistent thing but maybe this
is the better thing okay we've got a
third case if i understand correctly
only one more case and the the case
would be
this the option
here which i think and maybe that was
what gosha was saying should be called
variogram function
that's the option
you see what i'm saying very gram
function can take a varigram model
or it can take a variogram model
estimate
actually maybe it's most consistent to
call it estimated variogram model i
agree
take variogram function arrow estimated
variogram model the default would be
that variogram function
is estimated variogram model of the
original data
right
that's what it is now yeah okay so the
the the walk through this again because
there's changing a bunch of things okay
very gram function is the option do you
agree
fine
okay
variagram model
is the special function
an estimated variogram model is the
thing that returns the special function
from data
okay
okay
marco asks do we have the capability to
import wms tiles who knows what wms
tiles are
and yes we we do have ngos server wms
and wmts which is a tiled version of wms
okay and does that does that dovetail
with the spatial statistics stuff
properly or not
no i think it's just a method a
connection method a protocol method in
gear server
okay so the one further function i
haven't seen this is bendvariogram
what is bendvariogram
it's data
version of
variogram
so
the point is that when you when you look
at the definition of the of the
variogram it was for you know the was
that was looking at the variance between
the values of
of the field among two people so that's
probably been very example
that never happens in real life so you
look at the all the points within
certain distances
or is it something different
no there's not a model that's not a
model that's it's model free
yeah it's just it's gonna give you the
the data so it gives you the
the the basically it gives you the
weighted data but it gives you the
points at the distances and then the
average of this variance is at this
distance okay but it's returning it's
another animal that eats
okay so it's got the data but then it
returns something which just eats a
radius is that correct
no it does not
it does not
it returns weighted data
so the way that data gives you the the
you know the the points the the the data
from the weighted data it's something
that you create a list
plot with and the weights gives you the
number of pairs that each of this value
was for supporting we have to wrap up so
how good how valid your your value is
for the right i'm supposed to do another
live stream so we have to wrap up here
and i'm afraid we're going to need
another half hour
on this thing
um
okay okay so good stuff very interesting
and uh for folks who are interested
there is another
live stream about business and
innovation coming up which is uh
i really should go on with this but
we've scheduled that and i'm also being
told i should remind people that you can
sign up now
for
uh our technology conference which is
coming up in gosh very soon like a month
less than a month
wow that's coming up quickly wow we've
got lots of stuff to get ready for that
anyway people can um sign up for that
and uh have a chance to
have um
actual interactive discussions with
everybody everybody here and others
so
encouraged to sign up for that all right
have to wrap up here and we'll continue
this for another half hour